[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo ihr Lieben hier sind wir wieder
Toni Heyer und Mirko Kasimir herzlich
Willkommen zu Tatort Deutschland eurem
täglichen truecrime Podcast und heute
wird es verdammt makaber Mirko kurze
Frage zu Anfang ich möchte mit dir eine
Art kleines Gedankenexperiment machen
okay du hast nicht vor in nächster Zeit
Mörder zu werden oder
nein
derzeit habe ich nichts dergleichen
geplant okay sehr gut das ist schon mal
sehr sehr beruhigend aber nur mal
angenommen du würdest jemanden ermorden
was wäre dein größtes Problem das ist
jetzt ernst gemeint die Frage ja die
Frage meinst du ernst
okay naja es gibt da sicherlich eine
ganze Menge fangen wir mal damit an dass
ich naja wie sage ich sehr unangenehm
überrascht von mir wäre ja ich bin
eigentlich nicht so sehr der Typ der
sowas ja ja das ist alles schön und gut
aber lassen wir mal sowas wie dein
Gewissen und dass du netter Typ bist und
so das das lassen wir jetzt mal alles
beiseite was wäre dein größtes Problem
wenn du als Mörder ungeschoren davon
kommen willst na ja ich würde natürlich
versuchen alle Spuren so zu beseitigen
dass ich ungeschoren davon komme und das
betrifft natürlich in aller erster Linie
offensichtlich die Leiche genau in
vielen Fällen ist die gleiche das Opfers
sozusagen der letzte und beste Zeuge und
darum betreiben viele Mörder einigen
Aufwand um sie auch verschwinden zu
lassen ja ich erinnere mich das hatten
wir ja erst vor kurzem beim Säure warten
mörderfall ja der war heftig aber bei
unserem heutigen Fall da ist das ganz
anders Mirko für die Massenmörder
William Burke und William hair waren die
Leichen nicht das Problem sondern das
Motiv ihre Geschichte Mirko fangen wir
doch mal an okay wir gehen 200 Jahre
zurück in der Zeit
1827 Edinburgh die Hauptstadt von
Schottland ein wichtiges Handelszentrum
bekannt für seine Brauereien und
Druckereien und neben leiden in den
Niederlanden und Padua in Italien eins
der weltweit führenden Zentren für
anatomische Forschung und Ausbildung ich
habe da gar kein gutes Gefühl ja
hunderte lang war es ein absolutes Tabu
Menschen zu zitieren sei es aus
wissenschaftlichen Gründen um die
Todesursache festzustellen oder damit
angehende Chirurgen an Leichen üben
konnten stattdessen wurden z.B
schweineziert wobei es natürlich immer
Leute gab die sich darüber hinweggesetzt
haben klar Neugier lässt sich halt nie
ganz unterdrücken
im Zuge der Aufklärung jedenfalls kippte
das Tabu langsam eine Leiche
aufzuschneiden galt immer noch als
großer Frevel denn man am an dass es im
Leben nach dem Tode zu Problemen kommen
könnte wenn man dort in Einzelteilen
auftaucht darum war laut schottischem
Gesetz nur die Untersuchung von
hingerichteten Verbrechern und Menschen
erlaubt die im Gefängnis gestorben waren
und von Selbstmördern denen des
Himmelreich ja angeblich sowieso
verwirrt sein ja und das darf man auch
nicht verschweigen auch von Verstorbenen
weisen und Findelkindern klar die
konnten sich ja schon zu Lebzeiten nicht
werden fies hingerichtete waren aber am
beliebtesten das waren halt oft gesunde
und relativ junge Menschen es gibt
Berichte aus jener Zeit dass ich die
Studenten regelrecht unter dem Galgen um
die Leichen geprügelt haben sollen
das müssen wirklich unschöne Szenen
gewesen sein da war die Nachfrage
deutlich größer als das Angebot der
Bedarf wurde immer größer aber man
konnte ja nun schlecht anfangen die Zahl
der Hinrichtungen an der Zahl der
Medizinstudenten auszurichten die Anzahl
der Todesurteile ging sogar tendenziell
zurück sehr zum Bedauern der Anatom und
was passiert wenn die Nachfrage das
Angebot übersteigt richtig die Preise
gehen hoch in den 20er Jahren des 19
Jahrhunderts zahlte die Universität gut
und gerne acht bis zehn Pfund pro Leiche
klingt jetzt erstmal wenig damals aber
ein kleines Vermögen und natürlich gab
es eine Menge Leute die sich alle
erdenkliche Mühe gaben den naja
Versorgungsengpass zu überbrücken und
gut daran zu verdienen
und so schlug die Stunde der Grabräuber
das wurde bald zu einem Riesenproblem
also wirklich ein richtig großes Problem
ich meine wir haben zwar keine
verlässlichen Zahlen und bestimmt ist
auch ein bisschen Hysterie dabei gewesen
aber das war massiv die Leute wurden
auferstehungsmänner genannt und sie
klauten an Leichen was sie kriegen
konnten wer sich leisten konnte ließ
einen eisernen grabkäfig um das Grab
seiner Angehörigen bauen eine
Alternative waren super schwere
Steinplatten die man mieten und auf das
Grablegen konnte bis man sicher war dass
die betrauerten Liebsten zu verrottet
Warnung für den Leichen Tisch
interessant zu sein
Friedhöfe stellten Wachleute ein einige
gingen sogar so weit Wachtürme zu
errichten und es kam wiederholt zu
Demonstrationen in Edinburgh gegen das
Treiben der Grabräuber aber all das half
nicht viel solange es an Atomen gab die
bereit waren viel Geld für eine Leiche
zu zahlen und wenig Fragen zu ihrer
aufzustellen schlichen sich auch Leute
mit Schaufeln auf die Friedhöfe das
Geschäft lief allerdings auch nicht mehr
so gut zum einen weil Friedhöfe besser
geschützt wurden zum anderen weil es so
viele auferstehungsmänner gab
naja und in dieser Situation dachten
sich wohl William Burke und William her
moment mal Leichen kann man doch
eigentlich auch ganz einfach selbst
herstellen aus lebenden Menschen
Mirko ich denke du solltest jetzt mal
ein bisschen was über die beiden
erzählen na klar William Berg wurde 1792
in Irland geboren er hatte eine gute
Erziehung trat als Teenager der
britischen Armee bei und zog nach
Schottland eine erste Ehe ging in die
Brüche später heiratete er Helen mcduge
die er offenbar sehr liebte erinnerte
sie zärtlich Nelly
1827 zogen die beiden nach Edinburgh sie
arbeiteten erst als Straßenhändler dann
wurde Burg Schumacher es heißt er habe
einige Erfolg gehabt und gut verdient
mehr als ein Pfund pro Woche und er war
sehr beliebt während er von Haus zu Haus
zog um seine Schuhe zu verkaufen sang
und Tanz der oft für seine Kundschaft
und er hatte immer eine Bibel dabei
fröhlich und gottesfürchtig von diesem
Mann musste man nun wirklich keine Angst
haben William her war ein ganz anderer
Typ
die Angaben über sein Geburtsjahr
schwanken zwischen 1792 und 1804 Brian
Bailey beschreibt ihn in seinem Buch das
Jahr der gule so ungebildet und
ungehobelt ein hagerer streitsüchtiger
gewalttätiger und amoralischer Charakter
mit den Narben Alter Wunden an Kopf und
Stirn
seine Frau Margaret lehrt wird
beschrieben als hartgesottenes und
ausschweifendes Mannweib hui und
trotzdem wurden die beiden so
unterschiedlichen Paare Freunde nachdem
sie sich 1827 kennengelernt hatten die
vier zogen sogar gemeinsam in eine
Herberge in Edinburgh die William her
gehört hatte bald hatten sie einen Ruf
weg als besonders trinkfeste und
ausgelassene Leute einer der Mieter der
Herberge starb am 29 november 1827 an
Wasser sucht also Nieren oder
Herzschwäche das Problem für Herr war
dabei dass der Verstorbene ihm noch vier
Pfund Miete schuldete und das brachte
ihn und seine Frau auf die Idee seine
Leiche zu verkaufen
da der Mann keine Verwandten hatte
bezahlte die Gemeinde für ihn einen
einfachen Sarg der vorerst in der
Herberge verblieb in der Nacht vor der
Beerdigung öffneten William und seine
Nele diesen Tag entfernten die Leiche
versteckten sie unter einem Bett und
füllten den Sarg mit Rindenmulch am
nächsten Tag nach Einbruch der
Dunkelheit schleppten William her und
williamberg die Leiche zur Uni und
suchten dort nach einem Käufer klar ob
man nun rumrennt um Schuhe zu verkaufen
oder Leichen ich frage mich gerade ob er
da auch für die Kundschaft gesungen und
getanzt hat naja ich schätze mal eher
nicht aber sie hat noch so Erfolg ein
Anatom namens Robert Knox kaufte Ihnen
die Leiche für sieben Pfund und zehn
Schilling ab
verdammt viel Geld wenn man bedenkt dass
Burg als erfolgreich galt weil er mit
seinen Schuhen ein Pfund die Woche
verdiente da sind 7 Pfund und zehn
Schilling ein Vermögen
woher die Leiche kam interessierte den
Käufer nicht einer von Knox Assistenten
sagte sogar noch dass sie sehr froh
wären sie wiederzusehen wenn sie mal
wieder jemanden zu entsorgen hätten das
nennt man wohl einen Floh ins Ohr setzen
im Januar oder Februar nur zwei oder
drei Monate nach dem erfolgreichen
Geschäft wurde ein weiterer Mieter von
hairs Pension schwer krank nach was für
ein glücklicher Zufall natürlich nur für
Herr und Burg nicht für den Mieter einen
Müller namens Jonathan die beiden
planten bereits wie sie seine Leiche
verkaufen könnten aber der Mieter
weigerte sich hartnäckig zu sterben und
William und William wurden ungeduldig
und halfen nach zuerst fühlten sie ja
Opfer mit Whisky ab dann drückte her ein
Kissen auf den Kopf des Opfers während
sich Burg auf den Oberkörper des Mannes
legte
die Historikerin Lisa Rosner bezeichnete
diese mord-methode später als genial
gut das klingt für unsere Ohren sehr
mahaber ja aber wir hatten ja schon
gesagt dass es heute makaber wird stimmt
das geniale war laut Rosner dass das
Gewicht des zweiten Mannes das Opfer
bewegungsunfähig machte und verhinderte
dass er Luft holen konnte selbst wenn er
irgendwie dem Ersticken den Griff des
anderen entkam sie beschrieb dass ein so
ausgeführter Mord auch bis in die Ära
der modernen Forensik nicht nachweisbar
gewesen wäre
und wenn sie ihn zum Beispiel erstochen
hätten hätte sicher auch der
skrupelloses der Anatom ihnen keine
Leiche mehr abgekauft Burk wurde sogar
die zweifelhafte Ehre zuteil dass die
mord-methode nach ihm benannt wurde
working ist ein feststehender Begriff in
der Forensik und der amerikanischen
Rechtsprechung dieser erste Mord war aus
Sicht von Herr und Burg noch eine Art
nachhelfen sie ging davon aus dass der
Mann sowieso sterben würde es dauerte
ihn einfach nur zu lang
für die Leiche des Müllers erhielten sie
diesmal wieder von NOx 10 Pfund danach
wollten sie nicht mehr warten bis mal
wieder ein Mieter krank wurde es hatte
zweimal geklappt es würde auch ein
drittes Mal gut gehen und ein viertes
Mal und ein fünftes Mal und immer so
weiter das ist so ekelhaft die beiden
hatten ab diesem Zeitpunkt jede Hemmung
verloren das war Morden am Fließband
noch im Februar starb die
salzverkäuferin Abigail Simpson die
beiden gabelten sie angetrunken auf und
lockten sie in die Herberge wo sie
Abigail auf dieselbe Weise wie den
Müller töteten allerdings verwendeten
sie kein Kissen mehr sondern Herr hielt
ihr Mund und Nase zu während sich Burg
auf ihren Oberkörper legte
ihre Leiche ist noch besonders frisch
als sie sie abliefern und NOx zahlt mal
wieder Geld diesmal 15 Pfund sie töteten
weitere Mieter der Pension oder suchten
sich die Opfer auf der Straße die Sie zu
sich lockten und betrunken machten
einmal brachte Burke zwei Prostituierte
in die Pension
Janet Brown und Mary Patterson
Janet Brown verließ die Herberge nach
einem Streit Mary Patterson verließ sie
in einer Holzkiste als Übungsobjekt für
Medizinstudenten
Knox zarte 8 Pfund für die Leiche die
noch warm war als Herr und Burg sie bei
ihm ablieferten ja und als ob das nicht
schlimm genug wäre jetzt wird es richtig
fies einige der Medizinstudenten
erkannten die Frau die sie sezieren
wollten höchstwahrscheinlich weil sie
schon als Kunden bei ihr gewesen waren
ja und das war nun doch Fragen auf Knox
wollte wissen woher sie die Leiche
hätten
die Mörder behaupteten sie habe sich zu
Tode getrunken und sie hätten die Leiche
einer alten Frau im Stadtteil kennengeld
abgekauft
das war als Erklärung anscheinend völlig
ausreichend zu malen Knox von der Leiche
begeistert war und sie wohl nur ungern
wieder hergegeben hätte
skrupellos ja aber es wird noch
schlimmer NOx hat die Leiche der Frau
drei Monate in Whiskey eingelagert bevor
er sie sitzierte ach komm mir Gehör auf
man dieser NOx der ist mindestens
genauso schlimm wie die Mörder selbst
und sie kannten kein Ende und keiner
Barmen sie töteten eine Reisende
streichholzverkäuferin einen geistig
behinderten jungen Mann eine Bettlerin
und wie Burgers später in seinem
Geständnis erzählte eine alte Frau und
einen dummen Jungen ihren Enkel ja auch
vor Kindern machten sie nicht halt sie
töteten eine weitere alte Frau und
Wochen später deren Tochter sie töteten
ihre eigenen bekannten sogar Verwandte
von Nelly Box geliebter Frau mussten
daran glauben und übrigens die Frauen
wussten als ihre Männer da trieben ihr
letztes Opfer ist Margaret dockerty eine
ihren mittleren Alters die Burg in die
Pension eines Cousins lockte er hatte
behauptet seine Mutter sei ebenfalls
eine doppeltee und komme aus derselben
Gegend in Irland zu diesem Zeitpunkt
waren noch zwei andere Gäste anwesend an
und James grey und work versuchte sie
loszuwerden indem er sie dafür bezahlte
in hairspension umzuziehen ja ganz dick
im gästegeschäft aber logisch so war
immer für Nachschub für ihr eigentliches
Business gesorgt als sie allein waren
begannen Burger und Margaret doppeltee
zu trinken später kamen her und die
Frauen der beiden dazu zeugen
berichteten später sie hätten die fünf
betrunken singen und tanzen gesehen und
irgendwann am Ende der Party töteten sie
Margaret rockety toll die gleiche haben
sie dann erstmal in einem Strohhaufen am
Fuß eines Bettes versteckt und genau das
war ihr Pech zum Glück
am nächsten Tag kamen nämlich die
ausquartierten Grace zurück weil sie ein
Paar Strümpfe vergessen hatten ja damals
ging man noch ins Hotel zurück wenn man
ein Paar Strümpfe vergessen hatte
zu diesem Zeitpunkt war aber niemandem
Haus also suchten sie auf eigene Faust
statt ihrer Socken fanden sie eine
Leiche und zum Glück dachten sie nicht
an die acht oder zehn Pfund die sie
dafür bekommen könnten sondern gingen
zur Polizei auf dem Weg dorthin
begegneten sie Margaret mcduwe der Frau
von Berk die ihnen ein Schweigegeld von
10 Pfund pro Woche anbaut wenn sie
umkehrten aber auch darauf ließen sie
sich nicht ein William William Berg und
ihre Frauen sowie der Cousin und dessen
Herr Berge der letzte Mord stattgefunden
hatte wurden festgenommen den Cousin
ließ man bald wieder frei die anderen
kamen in Haft und wurden des Mordes
angeklagt
bald bekam die Zeitungen Wind von der
Sache und überboten sich mit
spektakulären berichten praktisch alle
vermissten der letzten Monate und Jahre
wurden zu Opfern der beiden Williams
erklärt aber es gab ein Problem es war
nämlich gar nicht so einfach den beiden
diese Morde nachzuweisen die Leichen
waren verschwunden dafür hatten die
fleißigen einer Turm in der Universität
gesorgt
Margaret dockettys Leiche war zwar noch
da zeigte aber keine Spuren von
Gewaltanwendung
man fand Indizien
Janet Brown identifizierte die Kleidung
von Mary Patterson ein Bäcker sah birks
Neffen in den Hosen eines vermissten
aber all das reichte nicht aus der
Advokat seiner Majestät sowas wie der
Chef Ankläger im damaligen Schottland
der Griff zu einer etwas zweifelhaften
Taktik
er versprach William herrscht
Straffreiheit wenn er ein umfassendes
Geständnis ab alle Details offen und
hinreichende Beweise für die Schuld
seines mit Täters offenlegte der Prozess
begann am Weihnachtsabend 1828 vor dem
Obersten Strafgericht in Schottland um 9
Uhr wurden die Türen geöffnet kurz
danach war der Gerichtssaal überfüllt
eine große Menschenmenge wartete vor dem
Parlamentsgebäude in dem das Gericht
seinen Sitz hatte
300 Polizisten mussten Verordnung sorgen
das Verfahren endete wie versprochen mit
einem Freispruch für Herr auch seine
Frau kam ungeschoren davon da er sie
nicht belastet hatte
works Frau entgegen nur knapp einer
Verurteilung wegen Mordes aus Mangel an
Beweisen für eine direkte Mittäterschaft
ihr Mann William Burke wurde wegen
Mordes zum Tode verurteilt insgesamt
hatten Burke und hair mindestens 16
Menschen aus reiner Profitgier getötet
vor Gericht waren aber nur drei Morde
verhandelt worden die man für besonders
beweissicher hielt
ich weiß ja nicht wie es euch geht bei
der Sache aber ich habe da jemanden auf
der Anklagebank vermisst du meinst
Robert Knox den Käufer der Leichen er
wurde vor Prozessbeginn befragt
allerdings nur als Zeuge er behauptete
die beiden hätten ihm erzählt dass sie
Armen Häuser in Edinburgh beobachteten
um dort Leichen zu kaufen bevor jemand
sie für eine Beerdigung beanspruchen
konnte und er kam damit davon aber ich
finde hier müssen wir mal ganz kurz über
seine Verantwortung reden
für mich ist das krasse bei bei NOx
diese bewusste
Ignoranz weil ich meine das ist so eine
Eigenschaft die wir alle glaube ich ein
bisschen in uns haben dass wenn wir in
einem System sind von dem wir
profitieren stellen wir das schon in
Frage aber nicht so kritisch wie wir es
vielleicht bei anderen ganz ganz weites
Feld was man damit aufmacht nee das kann
geht damit los dass ich Industriestaaten
gegenüber armen Länder nach wie vor
bereichern und ist natürlich in unserer
heutigen Geschichte so dass er seinen
Nutzen für sich als Wissenschaftler
daraus ziehen wollte und deshalb einfach
nicht weiter drüber nachgedacht wieso
ihm immer wieder perfekte Leichen
zugespielt werden ja es muss ihm doch
irgendwann auch wenn es nicht laut
ausgesprochen hat aber irgendwann muss
er doch mal inne gehalten haben und
darüber nachgedacht haben wie das
eigentlich sein kann
der ist nicht so viele Leichen zu sitzen
gab und plötzlich kommen diese zwei um
die Ecke und haben da eine perfekte
Leiche nach der nächsten am Start ja ich
meine spätestens das hätte ihm
vielleicht nach dem zweiten oder dritten
Mal klar sein müssen dass es kein Zufall
sein kann dass da irgendwie eine gewisse
Methode dahinter steckt und dass diese
Methode ja logischerweise irgendwie
nicht ganz rechtlich in Ordnung ist aber
macht er sich dann da mit schuldig auf
jeden Fall auf jeden Fall macht er sich
auf jeden Fall mit schuldig denn in dem
Moment spätestens dann wenn er genau
diesen Gedanken hat dass ihr weiß oder
sich selber eingestehen muss dass er
weiß dass es hier nicht mit rechten
Dingen zugehen kann spätestens dann
schon weil das ist der Moment wo er
eigentlich den Schlussstrich ziehen muss
vor sagen muss sorry irgendwas stimmt
nicht ja das stimmt wie sagt man auch
unwissenheit schützt nicht vor Strafe
unwissenheit schützt vor Strafe nicht ja
was hast du sehr gut gesagt hey Alter
danke aber Mirko zurück zum Fall wie
ging es denn danach weiter
ja immerhin war Knox Ruf danach ruiniert
was nur ein schwacher Trost her und die
beiden Ehefrauen kamen frei und flohen
aus Edinburgh über ihr weiteres
Schicksal ist nichts bekannt umso besser
wissen wir was mit William Burke
passierte am 28 Januar 1829 wurde er vor
25.000 Zuschauern gehängt doch damit ist
seine Geschichte noch nicht zu Ende der
Richter hatte dem Todesurteil nämlich
noch etwas hinzugefügt ihr Körper sollte
öffentlich seziert und anatomisiert
werden und ich vertraue darauf dass wenn
es jemals üblich sein sollte Skelette zu
konservieren auch dass ihre konserviert
wird damit die Nachwelt ihre grausamen
Verbrechen im Gedächtnis behalten kann
und so verschaffte williamberg dem
Anatomischen Institut der Universität
Edinburgh noch eine letzte Leiche seine
eigene ich muss sagen bisschen Karma am
ersten Februar wurde sie vor zahlreichen
Studenten zitiert und die makaberen
Details nehmen kein Ende während der
Prozedur tauchte der Anatom seinen
Federkiel in perksblut und schrieb dies
wurde mit dem Blut von William Burke
geschrieben denn Edinburgh gehängt wurde
das Blut wurde von seinem Kopf genommen
das Skelett wurde dem anatomischen
Museum Edinburgh Form macht und dort ist
es auch heute noch ja es gibt auch noch
so etwas wie ein Happy End aufgrund der
Morde wurde 1832 der Anatomy Act
verabschiedet der die Verwendung von
Leichen in der Medizin und Forschung
endlich regelte und darüber hinaus die
wie die Sektion hingerichteter
Verbrecher beendete so schlimm dass
alles auch war und schrecklich grausam
und perfide vor allem aber ich finde man
könnte fast ein bisschen sagen die
Barbarei der Mörder hat die Welt
letztlich ein bisschen zivilisierter
gemacht ja das also sehr vorsichtig
formuliert das ist eine wirklich sehr
positive und optimistische
Interpretation der ganzen Geschichte und
dabei sollten wir es belassen bevor uns
wieder etwas makaberes einfällt
unbedingt das war's für heute ein
wirklich bizarrer unglaublicher Fall wir
haben für diese Folge unter anderem die
Websites the Ministry of history.com
historic uk.com sowie die
englischsprachige Wikipedia verwendet
schön dass ihr dabei wart heute bis zum
nächsten mal eure Toni und euer Mirko
bis dahin ciao ciao Crypt und
Postproduktion Studios Redaktion Stefan
und Antonia Haier